it's really nice to be able to control
your own destiny and not to have anybody
kind of being able to tell you what to
do and I think that's given us the
agility and the flexibility to really
just do the right thing and move quickly
my name is Stefan Goss I'm 29 and I'm
busy of Zito you know I came to the US
when I was 19 by myself I was supposed
to do one exchange semester and I just
stayed I just never came home
I was in college I'm foreign so I wasn't
allowed to have a job I needed money and
so I tried to figure out how to make
money online so I started samples comm
and so the pipettes that became very
popular but we struggled actually
driving revenue so one of the things we
started doing we started asking the
visitors that came to our website
questions and we used those questions to
target ads to them and so basically we
found very specific data points about
our users that they volunteered and then
allowed advertisers to show ads against
that data and so about two years ago we
took that technology we built we spun it
out into a separate company called Zito
and that's what that's what I've been
doing since it's a tool for publishers
to monetize their user base most
advertising is very data-driven but the
data is really collected through a whole
bunch of other mostly kind of implicit
methods I think we're very different
because we actually just asked so I
think that really gives our advertisers
an edge and it's completely transparent
to the users as well well it's one of
the big trends we're seeing is that
Facebook and Google basically are just
absolutely dominating the online space
that trend of the consolidation towards
just the huge players has really been
tough on the smaller publishers so what
we're hoping is that it doesn't keep
consolidating on that side to where the
smaller publishers get pushed out and
then there's less of diverse content out
there
so I think we've made a ton of really
bad decisions but we've always been
strategic enough about it to make them
not so bad that everything sank we're
completely bootstrapped all of my
companies are so we've never raised any
money and so being very conscious about
not making any mistakes big enough that
you can't afford I have never had a boss
I've never had a job actually I never
really picked up any of those but
anybody else's habits either so I was
really able to kind of develop
everything kind of from scratch
you